[Music]
I heard about you
didn't think you agreed I'm realized
useful
it's really exciting to bring Batman
back to the big screen
[Music]
I'm putting together a team people with
special abilities stop right there
I mean I totally had a fan freakout
moment I cannot believe I'm standing
next to Batman Batman for the first time
understands that he can't do this by
yourself well this is the day is where
mom's biggest concerns were exploding
wind-up penguins a simple life in the
new movie Justice League we see the
evolution of a new Batman he's moved on
from lone vigilante to recruiter and
leader we get to enjoy the adventures of
this group as they saved world what are
your superpowers again I'm rich
I don't recognize this well I don't have
to recognize that we just have to save
it
I need to bring us together
[Music]
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
[Music]
Superman violence acts of war and
terrorism are all on the rise I had a
dream it was the end of the world
I think it's something more something
darker
we're asking people we'd unknown to risk
their lives strong man and strong us
alone
never heard that it's not a saying
that's the opposite of what the saying
is
divided we are not enough
[Music]
worldly Superman
[Music]
I made him a promise
so why I brought you together
ride ain't over yet man
[Music]
[Music]
Oh awesome as a bad thing oh that's your
sorry
it's your signal that means we have to
go now yeah I sort of mean it's so cool
[Music]